my name is Hank green I'm 28 years old I
live in the United States and I'm
lighting a candle of hope for Rwanda
[Music]
fifteen years ago generations of ethnic
hatred culminated in a hundred days of
killing in which over a million people
died two days ago I was on the phone
with a woman who is from Rwanda and
whose entire family died during those
100 days she had recently been able to
go to Canada to start school and was
aware every day of what was going on in
her country but when she watched the
news most of what she saw was one
in one white suburban running
away from the police meanwhile tens of
thousands of were killing
hundreds of thousands of people and no
one even talked about it let alone did
anything about it I think that we can
all be ashamed of this I think that
humanity requires us to be ashamed of
this one of the things that Sufi told me
that I found really fascinating actually
was that as horrible as it was that
these people knew that their friends
were dying and that they might very well
be killed soon as well what was worse
for them was the complete feeling of
abandonment as if no one in the world
cared what was happening to them which
frankly was the case now 15 years later
is the anniversary of the Rwandan
genocide approaches a huge number of
people are getting together and showing
the support for the people of Rwanda who
are still struggling through what the
genocide has meant for them and so what
John and I along with the Harry Potter
Alliance and candles for Rwanda are
asking you to do is simply show that you
care we as members of the international
community care about them as our
neighbors as our friends that we see
them as one of us and that we have hope
for their future the same way that we
have hope for ours so please make a
video that's less than 30 seconds long
of you lighting a candle saying who you
are and holding it for 10 seconds and
then follow the instructions in the
sidebar for how to send that video in
other things on the nerdfighter news
network today include Hank Green's
search for an Irish fiddle player are
there any Irish fiddle player
nerdfighters with good microphones
because if there are I think I need you
because I don't have any friends who
play Irish fiddle I'm writing an Irish
song that requires Irish fiddle so if
you would like to be on one of my songs
if you have a good microphone and you're
able to play Irish fiddle please email
me at sparks laughs at gmail.com second
nerdfighter extraordinaire Travis Richey
is vying to become a member of the big
gay sketch show and to do this he needs
your votes and all you need to do is go
click no signup is required just
so we need all of you to do that because
we need a nerdfighter on the big gay
sketch show there's a link in the
sidebar to do that as well all you have
to do is go to it and click on the vote
button preferably once per day for the
next seven days
John I've heard that your screenplay is
finished and that it's going over well
with your Hollywood overlords so I'm
excited about that and I'm especially
excited to see some footage of the
Netherlands but before that you'll be
seeing me again tomorrow